موقع لاطلاق الصواريخ الفضائيه الروسيه
اختاره فلاديمير بوتين للقاء كيم جون اون
المصافحه بين رئيس روسيا ونظيره الكوري
الشمالي استمرت لاربعين ثانيه واختيار
مكان اللقاء جاء تلبيه لتطلعات المهتمه
بتطوير برنامجها الفضائيه
عزيزي السيد الرئيس
انا سعيد جدا برؤيتك واستقبالك في روسيا
انه لشرف كبير ان يمنحنا الرئيس بوتين
المهتم ببرنامج الفضاء وزعيم القوه
الفضائيه فرصه لفهم وضع القوه الفضائيه
ومستقبلها
كوريا الشماليه تطرق باب روسيا للاستفاده
من خبراتها في الفضاء فهي تسعى لوضع قمر
اصطناعي للتجسس العسكري في المدار بحسب
مراقبين لان واشنطن تعتقد ان لقاء
الزعيميين له هدف اخر يتعلق بتزويد روسيا
باسلحه من كوريا الشماليه فموسكو تريد
صواريخ حربيه المضاده للدبابات وقذائف
مدفعيه كي تستخدمها في ساحات المعارك في
اوكرانيا الزعيم الكوري الشمالي المنبوذ
من المجتمع الدولي بسبب انشطته الصاروخيه
والنوويه المخالفه للقوانين الدوليه لا
يخفي انحيازه
مقدسه للدفاع عن سيادتها وامنها وعدالتها
في وجه المهيمنين
اغتنم هذه الفرصه لاؤكد اننا سنقف دائما
مع روسيا على الجبهه المناهضه للامبرياليه
وان كان في ابرام صفقه اسلحه بين بيون
بيانغ وموسكو انتهاكا للعقوبات الدوليه
واستفزازا للقوى الغربيه فانه ايضا ينطوي
على ازعاج للصين التي طالما اعتبرت نفسها
وصيه على كوريا الشماليه